what's up guys
bang bang it is lunch money time while
wall street is trying to get rich the
rest of us just trying to get our lunch
money right
that's right i'm here with clint evita
louisville marinova p-i-m-p
and she got her shirt on theprofile.com
go check it out
but don't forget that block five is now
the sponsor lunch money read the
profile.com guys
i don't even know the website no problem
blockfi is the sponsor of lunch money
that means you can earn up to eight
point six percent ep wide an interest
bearing account or you can go and you
can sign up for the bitcoin rewards
credit card it's a normal credit card
that is going to pay you bitcoin back
rather than cash
back that's right can't not complain
about that go to blockfy.com
pomp blockby.com pomp what's up
okay guys sorry that we haven't been
here for the last two days it's been
two days a lot friday and monday we
didn't film we didn't do friday one day
i was sick
yesterday i don't know what happened
it's okay this year it was my fault
we're here now okay bang bang we're here
so when paul tutor jones bet one to two
percent of his assets on bitcoin it was
unclear where the billionaire had bought
his crypto or how
but in the year since his firm the 44.5
billion dollar tudor investment
corporation
has indeed established rams for direct
crypto ownership it secured custodial
ties with institutional powerhouses
coinbase and backed you're gonna have to
get
exposure and if you're gonna have to get
exposure and you're a big firm then
you're gonna have to
do something uh with these companies and
so coinbase
uh block fi backed nydig
lmax digital just go down the line
over and over and over again there's all
these companies that are finding out
uh what does the institutional world
need and they're building solutions for
it so
it's pretty cool that the public
disclosures uh is what
allows us to figure that out but uh
let's go public disclosures
okay uh jay clayton the former chief of
securities and exchange commission
said bitcoin was not considered to be a
security of the agency but this does not
mean it should not be regulated
he said where digital assets land at the
end of the day will be driven in part by
regulation both domestic and
international
and i expect that regulation will come
in this area both directly and
indirectly
what is he saying you have to remember
that uh
the assets themselves can't be regulated
so the dollar is not regulated
bitcoin is not regulated gold is not
regulated
the institutions that participate with
these assets or support these assets so
that is what gets regulated
what are you gonna do to the dollar are
you gonna go arrest a physical dollar
are you gonna arrest a digital bitcoin
or a wrestling a borrower of gold
no what you do is the institutions that
support it but here is what everyone
forgets about this conversation
is that the bitcoin and crypto world is
more heavily regulated than any other
industry
in finance or vertical and finance what
i mean by that is one
if you're in the state of new york you
have to get a special license
to operate so on top of all the other
financial licenses and approvals that
you have to get for just being in
finance
you also have to get a crypto license so
that is more regulation rather than less
regulation than the traditional
financial companies
the second thing is that bitcoin as a
currency is
taxed every time you use it if i go use
a dollar at the grocery store i don't
have to pay tax when i spend the dollar
but if i spend bitcoin i actually have
to pay a tax again bitcoin the asset is
more regulated
it's more taxed than these other
currencies and so
this idea for some reason that bitcoin
is unregulated uh or the institutions uh
using bitcoin and supporting bitcoin are
unregulated it's just all talk
that's not true and actually the
counterfactual
ends up being where people need to focus
and so jay clayton did a great job of
stamping down on all the nonsense around
icos and and kind of all the bad acting
that went there so he should get kudos
for that
but when it comes to bitcoin we also
have to have serious conversation about
it already is regulated it's over
regulated in many cases
and we probably should be looking at
creating an even playing field between
the traditional financial system
and the new digital financial system
you're so smart
i don't know about that just okay the
sacramento kings are set to become the
first major sports franchise to offer a
bitcoin payment option
to all players and staff team owner
vivec
rana devay sat on clubhouse on monday
coined us confirmed with fellow speakers
on clubhouse
that uh vivec had preview previewed his
announcement schedule for later this
week
wow would they get anything else up in
here keep going
what you mean damn they just ain't going
all right here's the true story
do we get an exclusive i think
i think vivec will uh will enjoy me
telling this so
i met vivec we two or three years ago
uh there's a person that works with a
vec named ian wheat
ian was i think the director of
innovation uh and then ryan montagna was
the
uh cto i think of the uh sacramento key
money exclusive right here
and i've known these guys for a while
they're very very forward-thinking the
sacramento kings have an amazing stadium
uh everything from uh led lights to a
retractable roof
solar panels they've got a
state-of-the-art data center within the
sacramento king stadium all this stuff
so i went out there
planet came with me uh we spent a bunch
of time talking to
uh vivec to ryan to ian to uh the
president of the team
and we basically just went through that
what are all the different things that
they could do everything from tokenizing
ownership of the team
to uh bitcoin to mining etc many people
don't remember that the sacramento kings
actually set up
a mining facility bitcoin mining
facility uh
inside of their data center and they
donated the proceeds
so they've been ahead of the curve for a
while about a week ago
i had a phone call with ian and vivec
and
they were talking about hey what are the
things that we should be thinking about
and i gave them a whole bunch of
different ideas uh and one of them
is listen every single team is
eventually going to pay the players
in dollars and in bitcoin they're gonna
let the players choose
so why not be the first now here's where
the story gets interesting
it's simple to give somebody an idea but
what
ends up happening and ian's been a big
part of this but vivec
is ultimately kind of the driver as the
owner of the organization
is vivec immediately took action and so
that propensity for action is exactly
why he is a great entrepreneur
and he said let's do it let's go figure
out how to go do that and so they start
to put the wheels in motion to actually
execute on this
but what ends up occurring is that when
one nba owner does it another is going
to do it another and eventually the
lee's going to do it and then all these
other leagues are going to do all these
other teams are going to do it
and so what ends up happening is similar
to michael saylor being the first public
company ceo to go ahead and say i'm
going to take majority of my balance
sheet i'm going to put it in bitcoin
then open the floodgates and all these
other people started to do it people
started to talk about it
vivec is going to end up being the
forward-thinking innovative leader when
it comes to
paying players in bitcoin he's gonna be
the first one to get it done i think
and when he gets it done i don't know
how many players are gonna take
some bitcoin maybe some of them take one
percent or five percent maybe somebody
says hey pay me all of my salary bitcoin
i'm not sure but we've seen russell kong
do this in the nfl
i think we're going to see this happen
now in the nba i know there's a number
of people who i don't know if they want
to be
uh told or not but he's tweeting it so
i'm going to say his name
matthew dellavedova i've had him on the
podcast i've become uh
friendly with him and he he now is
tweeting out things like pay me in
bitcoin and so you can see the players
starting to
uh really really push into this world
understand it they understand their
their careers don't last forever and
they want to understand
uh investing alternative assets bitcoin
crypto etc and so i think this is a
really really cool thing
people are going to laugh at it people
are going to uh kind of mock the fact
that
an mba owner is doing this but i think
that vex is going to be on the right
side of history here
and so it's awesome to see them doing
this if you work for the profile i can
pay you in bitcoin
i ain't got paid a bitcoin you don't
work for the profile
okay uh must be an unpaid internet okay
top auction house sotheby's uh has
announced its first auction with
nft based digital artworks created by
anonymous artist pack
uh that scrutinizes our understanding of
value so the visa launched on monday
the fungible collection by pac will be
taking place april 12th through the 14th
on nifty gateway
which is the marketplace marketplace
owned by gemini which is owned by
um um the winklevi twins which there is
a great profile and forbes on them right
now
uh yeah that's it this is going to be
really really cool
he's already did the 69 christie oh that
was christy christie's did it now
southerly southern
is a very old uh auction house i think
it was 19 or 17 44.
you think you saw it right here
established in 1744 in london
i tried to test her knowledge got her uh
but
i think when you watch this play out
what you're starting to see is there's a
blending
is value in the art or is value in the
format uh and what i think we're
starting to understand is maybe it's
actually more in the art and the story
than it is in the format
what's the difference between painting a
mural or simply having it digital
well the value is derived by the
audience and so some people are going to
say
i want the painting and the digital
thing is worthless other people are
going to say i want the digital version
and the painting is worthless
so what you're starting to see is you're
seeing a transition in the audience and
the demand side of the equation
and so now there are auction houses
they're saying wait a second
maybe we should get in the game and
serve the people who want the digital
piece
not just the physical piece and so i
think that you're going to continue to
see this happen more and more
do you think it was a big deal when like
wine started being auctioned off for
insane prices
no why because that's how auctions work
because people show up and the market
decides
should i should should i create an
auction house for what
i might create an auction house that's
what i should do
that'd be fun huh what can i auction
i'ma auction you off
anthony
i don't have energy or time for this
today
okay this is fun okay speaking of nfts
two coinbase employees
have managed to find a heartwarming use
of for nfts by incorporating them into
their wedding
exchanging the digital tokens as part of
the ceremony
rebecca rose and peter kotcherzynski
uh say that alongside their traditional
jewish ceremony the couple will also
send each other digital
tokens as virtual rings to each other
wow that's so funny
i love this so their virtual rings now
exist on the blockchain for all to see
is proof of our commitment to each other
i love this this is amazing i think
we got married on the blockchain
however we not we exchanged real rings
except his
is like 17 on amazon he didn't want a
real one
he didn't want a real he wanted a pla
like show them how it stretches
yeah it stretches 17 on amazon
but a lifetime of memories it wasn't it
was it was something else
i can't remember all right next it was
seventeen dollars though
uh next is ask lunch money time hashtag
ask ellen below
we aka you still have not
messaged moist moisten is coming i am
sorry
but alexandria had a great question
she says what does paulina skincare
um okay well so i don't really wear
makeup but
i do have in terms of skincare i have
this face wash
god what is it called it's the one with
like the the bacteria that like
oh i'll i'll drop it in the comments
but basically it's this is not a beauty
influencer moisturizer and i really
really like the mario badescu
is that how you say it uh products
they're cheap and they're super
effective and high quality do you want
to tell people what you got me to do
finally
he uses moisturizer now aveeno my
my entire life for for all you men out
there you know real
men i was 27 years old when i met my
beautiful wife right here
and she asked me once how do you wash
your face what do you use
and i had to think for a second and then
i said to her
one of the most scary things that she's
ever heard well
which was i don't think i've ever washed
my face
other than in the shower with the bar of
soap going like this that's what scared
me because he washes his body and then
his face
no face then body it's soap it's clean
okay
but the the thing for men it's a little
different because you don't wear makeup
you don't
have like for yourself whatever like you
can just like wash your face it's not as
bad
but no i never like i i don't think i
ever even knew that there was special
soap for your face that's okay but see
now i upgraded your life
and now every morning i wake up and i
put this stuff and i go like this and i
try not to get it in my eyes
he puts it like uh like i do
i mean i'm going to go to battle today
so i might as well put on the war
painting like what's right
face cream and then i feel like yeah i'm
ready to take on the day ain't nobody
gonna mess with me today
i'm going to battle i got my face paint
war paint on let's go
and then i like do it so it doesn't look
weird for the rest of the day well there
you go guys now you know
see ya bang bang hope you guys enjoyed
this episode of lunch money as much as
we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block five is my second favorite thing
in the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to eight point six percent interest
on a deposit in an interest bearing
account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but eight point six percent
is pretty compelling
so click on the link in the description
say thanks to the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends